[Music]  in the woods today  la discovered a charming little land  work  but that sanitary place to bury our pets  and remember them which seems scary but  it's not perfectly natural  just like dying is natural old towns  been using this place for generations  folks make a kind of ritual out of it  it's not some campfire story so these  are the trees up there they're warnings  the local tribes carved in before they  fled they fear that place there's  something up there something that dates  way back  those woods belong to something else  something that cat was dead that brings  things back  I know what you're thinking of doing but  they don't come back the same whose wits  coil [ __ ] you daughter I should never  have shown you that place your child is  not the only thing that will come back  the barrier is broken  we have a second chance  sometimes dead is better  [Music]  you